مع مرور شهر على الاشتباكات المسلحه في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
شهدت مدينه الجنينه غربي دارفور اشتباكات
بين الدعم السريع ومجموعات المسلحه سقط
على اثرها نحو 200 قتيل خلال يومين دارت
ايضا اشتباكات متفرقه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع في مناطق جنوب الخرطوم وام
درمان وتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بخرق
اتفاق الجده الرامي لتوفير ممرات امنه
للمدنيين وتزامنت هذه التطورات مع بدء
المرحله الثانيه من المفاوضات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مدينه جده
السعوديه بحضور ممثلين للوساطه الامريكيه
والسعوديه
معنا بالعمرمان مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت
يعني كثير
يحدث الان في السودان احداث الجنينه
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم بحري لكن ايضا
القرارات الخاصه بالبنك المركزي
الصدر من عبد الفتاح البرهان ما تاثيرها
هل هل بالفعل هذه هذه القارات يمكن ان
تؤثر في سير الامور
طبعا هذه هي القرارات التي صدرت هي في
اطار التضييق الخناق على قوات الدعم
السريع من قبل رئيس مجلس وقائد الجيش في
خضم هذه المعارك المحتدمه ميدانيا وايضا
الان هناك اتجاه لهذه المعارك السياسيه
والاقتصاديه صح التعبير على هذه القوات
باعتبار ان اي محاولات لصرف هذه فيما يخص
تجميد الحسابات طبعا قبل قرار بتجميد كافه
الحسابات
ويعني عدم صرف اي ميزانيات كانت مرصوده
لهذه القوات من هذه البنوك سواء كانت داخل
السودان او خارج السودان ولكن بالنظر الى
الاوضاع الميدانيه الان الجاريه في
الخرطومه تحديدا
البرهان على البنك المركزي في ولايه
الخرطوم
البنوك طبق طبعا العمليات الصرف بالنسبه
لاي قوات او اي جهات حكوميه تتم عن طريق
البنك المركزي الذي يوجه احيانا صرف هذه
مباشره من البنك المركزي او توجيهي للبنوك
الاخرى التي تتعامل معها ولكن طبعا هي
عمليا لديها تاثير اقتصادي اذا كانت هناك
انظمه مصرفيه تعمل بالتاكيد سواء كان في
الداخل او في الخارج ولكن في ظل هذه
الظروف الان العمليه الشغاله تعمل في
الميدان ربما من الصعب الان العمل على
يعني صرف اي استحقاقات موجوده ولكن هذا
القرار طبعا له تبعات ما بعد هذه المرحله
خاصه اذا ما كانت هناك هدنه حقيقيه او
هناك اتجاه لخفض التصعيد بعد تفاهمات جدا
الجاريه الان وربما اذا ما عاده الامور
الى نصابها بشكل يعني تدريجي يعني تحرم
هذه القوات بنص هذه القرار من ان تستفيد
من اي امتيازات اقتصاديه او ماليه من
البنوك والمؤسسات الحكوميه الرسميه
بموجب هذا القرار هذه القرار طبعا تاتي في
اطار هذا الضغط الذي يتماشى ولكن يعني
العمليات الميدانيه هي التي الان يعني
تسيطر على المشهد الميداني رغم ان هناك
الان مع اتجاه يعني لايجاد اتفاق يقضي
بوقفي اطلاق النار ولكن ما زال نشات هذه
الهجمات وما نزل نشات هذا التصعيد المستمر
حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك هيثم ويت منهم
درمان مراسل الجزيره